look at how quickly he redirected the
conversation
from the nature of their commercial
paper to
hey listen we're the most popular the
market voted for us
therefore it cannot be a fraud there's
nothing to see over here
now is it possible that he's trolling
all of us and their paper is amazing
i guess when i saw that there are
nothing come apart or anybody who
watched the
bernie madoff thing come apart with his
uh fraud
they really redirected and attacked the
critics
and just moved the conversation from hey
whatever you're looking to get clarity
on let's forget about that and let's
talk about something
else as retail facing entrepreneurs what
does that mean
did you hear them say that as retail
facing entrepreneurs retail facing would
be
consumers and entrepreneurs people who
build businesses
we value it makes no sense so this
posturing
and this positioning that the market has
voted for us is i think
um something i don't buy later on in the
interview tethers general counsel
uh stuart hogner was asked about the
attestations uh over audits and here was
his
answer this is another thing that people
uh
are very confused about releasing a pie
chart is not the same
as giving us the details as to what
tether owns
and so let's hear his answer so the
attestations are part of
assurance services offered by
independent accountants
audits are another form of assurance
services deirdre
for now we are providing those quarterly
attestations those assurance testations
showing that tether is in fact fully
backed in reserve
we are working towards getting financial
audits
which by the way no one else in the
stablecoin sector has
done yet um we are seeing uh who will
get there first but we are
in process we are getting that done um
audit services
have not been widely available inside
the crypto
economy as a whole everyone is still
learning about this
but we are working towards getting those
audits now and in the meantime we are
providing the assurance attestation
so if they are the leaders in
transparency why can't they just have an
audit it doesn't make any sense and
you notice this like vague language
we're working towards it
uh the industry is working towards it
just get the audit
i mean if it's not rocket science here
folks you open your books up you have an
order they audit your books
so they're falling back to the
attestation which is somebody looks at
a brief snapshot in time at this moment
do you have these assets
and do you say you have these assets but
is anybody seen the commercial paper has
anybody seen those documents
i don't think so and that's why people
are demanding an audit here i think
what's going to happen is they're going
to quickly run into like regulation at
tether
and circle and other places where they
just say here's the new rules for stable
coins
you have to give us every week every day
every month whatever it is
audits from a legitimate auditor
not a cayman islands or an offshore
auditor bahamas whatever
just somebody who's actually known here
who has a license and could go to jail
in the united states
if they um don't do the audit properly
nobody has done it yet it's a pretty
crazy deflection there i think
nobody has done it yet doesn't mean you
shouldn't do it and if you have 62
billion dollars
in people's money and stable coins like
why wouldn't you
do it uh and this is what i always get
to if
everything's on the up and up people
tend to just say here's the goods
right if it was a poker game and you've
got the best hand you turn over your
cards as quick as possible you say
here's the best hand
you're not going to delay you ever be in
a po ever been in a poker game where
somebody doesn't want to turn their
cards over at the end and people like oh
no you have to turn yours over first
it's like just turn your cards over
let's see open kimono show us what you
got if you've got the goods you would
show us
if you don't have the goods you wouldn't
show us is
the general rule of thumb you'd have to
ask what is the other circumstance in
which they wouldn't
tell us hey it's time for another r
crowd deal of the week right now you can
join our crowd's investment in
ripple according to the deal memo ripple
is an established innovator in the
rapidly growing multi-billion dollar
dairy alternative market ripple offers
alternatives to milk
protein shakes creamer and more with
proprietary tech
that lowers impurities for superior
taste and nutrition
you can get in early on ripple and other
unique opportunities
by signing up for a free account at
allcrowd.com
twist by the way did you know our crowd
investors were able to get in on some of
the best ipos of 2019 and 2020
they benefited from companies ipo like
beyond meat and lemonade
and some of our crowds companies have
been acquired by buyers like intel nike
microsoft oracle and
uber with our crowd accredited investors
can invest
easily and directly in startups early
before the ipo or get bought
as you review deals you have access to
our crowd's investor relation team
who you can talk to directly on the
phone about your personal investment
goals again the our crowd account is
free just go to
o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d dot com slash twist
once again our crowd.com twist and get
that account for free right now